the liberal media melting down after top
intelligence officials testified on Isis
North Korea and Iran president Trump and
his intelligence chiefs are worlds apart
on Isis Russia and the board this was
essentially a public repudiation by his
own people of donald trump's world views
like these intelligence leaders were
describing a different planet than the
one donald trump in half of growing
disparity between the ground truth that
they presented and the planet that this
president was on where does the
president get intelligence and foreign
policy advice from not agreeing with
these conclusions is willful disregard
of the facts this is dangerous
isn't this is a dangerous thing
after that media freak out the president
calling his intel chiefs extremely
passive and naive when it comes to Iran
all right Dana well I guess the
president has made the media take the
side of the Intel agencies they've never
done that before
after a doubt in 2003 but what do you
think's going on here with the president
and his and his men at the top well
here's the thing like I understand that
the media liked the story and we cover
it all the time - it's the story between
about the president and the media right
I'm actually melting down about the
threats no yeah because these are it's
like super serious we're behind on the
cyber war that's especially from China
and Russia I I look forward to this
hearing every year because I want to
know okay what word - the Intel so the
day before no I look and he also he said
in his tweet that they should go back to
school and he's just throwing some
chairs but look they work very hard for
him every day did you say throwing shade
yeah is that all you are oh my gosh yeah
you know you're Schultz and Christie
interview it all went to your head great
what do you think's happening here I
mean I did the president's always been
very suspicious of the Intel people
after the WMD thing and you know they
spied on his campaign it didn't like
that either it's weird the media is
demanding that everybody agree their day
they can't be happy
they call it disparity but it's not
lockstep it's it's they want lockstep
and if they don't see it then it's
called disparity
they keep parsing over his tweets at
like they're like old guys on the beach
with metal detectors hoping to find a
bottle cap meanwhile they overlook
bigger stories that that perhaps this is
working I mean the fact that the good
cop bad cop thing that was going on with
Syria I think might be working North
Korea had a good cop bad cop thing where
people were disagreeing that seems to be
working if you still do not believe
there isn't any progress there when you
say that oh it's disparity that they're
saying nothing's happening something's
up it's actually better than it was last
year and you have to admit it and you
can hold to ideas in your head we are
destroying Isis we will continue to
destroy Isis it doesn't have to be you
know the prison of two ideas you said we
destroyed Isis but they're still here
you can actually have both we are
destroying and continuing to destroy the
media wants you to be in their prison of
two ideas let them stay in there you
have a free mind you can you are smarter
than they are
and you make more money than they are
Jessa there's plenty of room for
skepticism when it comes to what the
intelligence community is staying in the
sourcing that these media outlets are
using to push a certain agenda when it
comes to foreign policy however when it
comes to the threats that we do face I
was at a cybersecurity panel last week
at the foundation for defense of
democracies and they were saying
basically with cyber the good news is
that we're both both adversaries the
United States Russia China are both bad
at responding and they're not and
they're better at attacking so that's
there their analysis we have to get
better at cyber it's a very serious
thing that's coming down the pike there
was talk of ways to respond to that so
while we're all you know fighting over
who said what and who agrees with what
there are real things that are happening
behind the scenes that we need good
people to be doing and so when it comes
to the ISIS thing yeah
where´s we've seen a number of Isis
attacks after the president has said
directly they've been defeated is he
talking about the territory yes does it
mean that Isis defeated all around the
world no I got a press release today
someone got arrested in the United
States again for giving material support
to Isis but that comes down to the
ideology of
like radicalism and what are approaches
to that maybe I'll congresswoman from
Minnesota can write a letter of support
one to Dana's point about the threats
there there are a lot of really serious
threats out there but the president's
been pretty strong on on Isis on North
Korea on China on Russia it would be
very he's been effective on those area
you know this I'm listening to this
defense coming from at least three of
you and I just think it's tissues then
it's just but I guess you're desperate I
guess that's what it is you thin rather
than because you have Trump's people
these are Trump's people saying we are
doing a realistic assessment and we all
agree it's not a matter of disagreeing
there's no no this is FBI CIA director
of national intelligence putting
themselves on the line before you the
American people and saying here's the
reality it's not what this guy's saying
not what Trump saying they don't mention
the southern border for example as an
immediate threat national no no they're
talking about China and Russia
increasingly working together against us
second North Korea he's going to go meet
again you say wait a second for what
what and he says oh well things are
better than no according the
intelligence they're still intent on
creating nuclear weapons and how about
it wasn't lost Iran they said Trump is
like oh yeah Iran isn't terrible no
intelligence they're not violating the
terms of the Obama agreement but you
never hear this Venezuela is now
responding saying that they are willing
to cooperate must submit Bolton's
Notepad people cook the books and say
that you know what not that big of a
threat anymore and then the rise of Isis
he blamed the Intel agencies for missing
it remember today and he weaponized the
Intel agencies to go after look I got
old Trump's I tell you what let's do a
current of beers news show on Fox News
Channel right now today you know what we
learned we learned the Trump got talking
with Putin privately he doesn't have a
translator Hooten has a translator
Putin has AIDS we don't
translates the reutilization sour grapes
oh yeah that's it